and speak in a Time gaps these actors
are aging The Duffer Brothers have to
address it in the most logical way a
Time jump they did speak out about it
and confirm it was inevitable as part of
the upcoming narrative I'm sure we will
do a time Jump ideally we'd have shot
season four and five back to back but
there was just no feasible way to do
that ideally because season four and
five are so connected it would have been
great to shoot them back to back because
the actors would be the same age but
because that's not possible they'll have
to write that change into the narrative
the only thing that won't be included in
the time Jump will be the upside down
it's stuck on the day that will was
brought there that's a huge plot point
of season five